>>> HAPPY WEDNESDAY.
LISTEN, MORPHING OPPONENTS IS
ONE WAY TO BECOME A BASKETBALL
IMMORTAL BUT TOUGHER THAN THE "!
2" OR THE PLAYERS PLAYING INSIDE
OF PFIZER ARENA IN MILWAUKEE.
WE'RE BETTING ON A NEW LEGACY IN
THE NBA FINALS.
WELCOME.
ERIN KAY DOLAN.
GREG COULDN'T BE WITH HERE.
I'M GIVING OUT THE GOODS AND THE
SUNSET VIBES.
GREGG IVORY ON TWITTER.
TONIGHT'S GAME FOUR THE SUNS AND
THE BUCKS SERIES IN THE NBA
FINALS, PHOENIX LEADS 2-1 GAMES.
WE GAVE AWAY A LOT OF FREE KICKS
IN THE LAST SHOW AND GIVING AWAY
MORE FREE KICKS IN THIS SHOW.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY UP TO FIVE
GRAND IN SNEAKERS DURING THE
FINALS AND TODAY GIVING OUT SIX
$250 SNEAKER GIFT CARDS TOWARD
ANY KICKS YOU WANT.
I'LL GIVE OUT THREE PAIRS ON THE
SHOW AND BET SOCIAL AND BR APP
AND BR KICKS GIVING AWAY ANOTHER
PAIR.
GET THE UPGRADE IN YOUR
WARDROBE.
I'M GREGG, THE G FEELING
GENEROUS.
I'LL GIVE AWAY $250 OR A FREE
PAIR OF KICKS TOWARDS THAT.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT PAIR OF SNEAKERS WOULD YOU
BUY IF YOU GOT ONE OF THE GIFT
CARDS.
LAST WEEK WE EASED ERIN SHE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY Js IN HER
WARDROBE.
YOU SPENT THE WEEKEND IN MIAMI.
DID YOU PICK UP A NEW PAIR OF
KICKS OR Js?
>> LAST THING WHEN I WAS
ENJOYING MYSELF IN MIAMI WAS
PURCHASING Js.
I NEED TO DO IT.
THEY'RE STYLISH, ALWAYS IN BUT
NOW IN FOR GIRLS SO I NEED TO
GET A PAIR.
>> WAIT, ERIN, YOU ARE ON SOUTH
BEACH, DO YOU HAVE A FRESH PAIR
OF KICKS?
>> I WAS IN HIGH HEELS.
>> WALK ALONG OCEAN OR COLLINS?
>> I WAS ONLY WEARING HEELS.
I WASN'T WEARING SNEAKERS.
IT WAS SO HOT AND HUMID, AND NOW
I CAN'T WALK BECAUSE I WAS IN
HEELS FOR EIGHT HOURS STRAIGHT.
>> OKAY, SO WE DEFINITELY NEED
TO GET YOU ONE OF THESE GIFT
CARDS.
>> YES, I WISH.
MAYBE I SHOULD BE IN THE
COMMENTS.
YOU'LL SEE ME COMMENTING.
>> YOU SHOULD BE, HELP ME OUT.
WITH THE STOCK OF SNEAKERS, TIME
TO UPGRADE SOMEBODY'S
COLLECTION.
I'LL GIVE OUT A PAIR, I'M IN THE
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
AND LET ME SEE HERE.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
OOH, JORDAN FOURS, TAXI 12s, NOT
KYRIE IRVING, I LIKE THAT.
BAD SPORTS TAKES, DUNK LOWS, 21
SR OFF WHITES ALWAYS ICONIC.
>> I LOVE OFF WHITE.
>> LET'S SEE HERE.
LeBRON 12s, JOEY 31 700 NOT BAD.
JORDAN 11s.
SILLY ERIC, AIR MAX 97s.
I LIKE THAT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
STILL LOOKING FOR --
>> I LOVE THAT WE'RE GIVING SOME
AWAY RIGHT AWAY.
>> YES.
>> THE COMMENTS.
>> IT'S REALLY BECAUSE THE G
MONEY, HE'S SO GENEROUS.
LETS ME KICK IT OFF WITH GROUP
CHAT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE, I DID SEE A
NICE LITTLE GIF, OOH, NAMELESS,
I LIKE THAT GIF RIGHT THERE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE
THAT, JUST A PAIR OF KICKS OVER
THE WORLD.
THAT'S PRETTY DOPE, NAMELESS.
BECAUSE YOU GAVE US THAT DOPE
GIF, NAMELESS, YOU ARE GETTING A
FREE PAIR OF KICKS, $250 SNEAKER
GIF CARD.
WE LOVE GIFs.
GIVE US GIFs.
>> AS MANY GIFs AS POSSIBLE.
>> YOU WILL GET A "GIFT" IN
RETURN.
THE SNEAKER KING P.J. TUCKER
WILL HAVE ALL OF OUR ATTENTION.
EVERY TIME HE ENTERS THE
BUILDING HE MULTIPLE PAIRS OF
HEAT ON HIS FEET.
THEY NEVER MISS A DETAIL OR PAIR
OF KICKS.
SALUTE TO THEM AND P.J. TUCKER.
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO IS A
UNICORN GROWN INTO A FULL
FLEDGED GOD.
A GREEK GOD IS IN EFFECT.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL EARLIER,
HOW MANY SPORTS WILL HE SCORE IN
GAME FOUR.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL US HOW
MANY POINTS THE GREEK FREAK IS
PUTTING UP TONIGHT.
AT THE END OF THE GAME WE'LL DM
ONE PERSON WHO GOT CLOSEST AND
HOOK YOU UP WITH $250 IN SNEAKER
MONEY.
ERIN, GIANNIS' SCORING PROP IS
34 1/2 POINTS.
YOU GOT THE OVER OR THE UNDER?
>> BOTH INTERESTING.
JIAN US IS ONE OF FOUR PLAYERS
TO HAVE SCORED 100 POINTS IN HIS
FIRST NBA FINALS GAMES.
HE SEEMS LOW FOR A PLAYER
BACK-TO-BACK 40-PLUS PERFORMANCE
BONUSES, WITH GIANNIS AVERAGE 38
IN THE FINALS.
THIS IS A HOT TAKE BUT I'M GOING
UNDER 34 1/2, I THINK THIS GAME
WILL BE MORE DEFENSIVE WITH THE
SUNS PROBABLY CHANGING THEIR
ENTIRE GAME PLAN, TRY TO SHUT
DOWN THE GREEK FREAK AND
ULTIMATELY I'M NOT SAYING HE
CAN'T SCORE FOR 30 BUT TAKING
UNDER 34 1/2.
THAT'S WHAT MY GUT IS SAYING.
THE WORD ON THE STREET, GABBY,
YOU'RE NOT AGREEING WITH ME.
>> THAT'S THE CORRECT WORD ON
THE STREET.
DID YOU WEAR RED BECAUSE YOU
KNEW YOU WERE FIRING OFF HOT
TAKES?
>> I WANTED TO WEAR PURPLE BUT
TOLD TO CHANGE MY OUTFIT AND
THAT'S WHY I'M IN THIS COLOR.
>> I'M ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS
DEBATE.
I LIKE THE TRANSPARENCY.
IT'S WONDERFUL.
I LIKE THE OVER.
GIANNIS IS IN THE COMFORT OF HIS
HOME GYM AT THE PFIZER ARENA,
HIS OWN BED WHICH IS PROBABLY 11
FEET LONG.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE.
>> RIGHT?
HE'S SPENDING TIME WITH HIS SON,
LIAM, HIM AND HIS LADY ARE
WELCOMING CHILD NUMBER TWO.
NOBODY AT PFIZER ARENA IS
COUNTING UPWARDS MOCKING HOW
LONG HE TAKES TO SHOOT A
FREE-THROW FROM THE FREE-THROW
LINE.
IT'S A COMFORTABLE BUILDING.
THE GUY'S BEEN PLAYING AMAZING,
LIKE LEGENDARY.
HE'S BEEN SO AMAZING.
LIKE AT THE RIM, IN THAT
RESTRICTED AREA HE SCORED 13 OF
14, SO HE'S PUTTING IN WORK.
NOBODY CAN STOP HIM IN THE
PAINT.
GIVE ME GIANNIS OVER 34 1/2
POINTS AND THE BUCKS W.
TIE UP THE SERIES IN THE NBA
FINALS, A BIG ONE TONIGHT AT
9:00 P.M. EASTERN.
I'LL GET IN THE COMMENTS.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
I LIKE THIS ONE FROM BEAST NOOK
999, GIANNIS 41 POINTS, 16
REBOUNDS AND 8 ASSISTS.
YOU'RE GETTING A HOODIE.
I LIKE THE SPECIFICITY OF THE
LINE THERE.
>> DOUBLE-DOUBLE THERE.
>> YES.
THEN NOT DWIGHT SHROOT.
27 POINTS AND THREE OF THEM FROM
THE FREE-THROW LINE.
JUST THREE.
>> JUST THREE.
LAST TIME HE HAD 13.
HE SCORED 13 LAST GAME.
>> YES, WHAT A DOWNGRADE.
LISTEN, 27 POINTS, THREE FROM
THE FREE-THROW LINE THAT'S A HOT
TAKE.
DWIGHT YOU GET A HOODIE.
I LIKE, LET'S SEE HERE, LET ME
GET ANOTHER ONE.
LEGENDARY CCD 32 POINTS FOR THE
GREEK FREAK TONIGHT, STILL UNDER
THE 34 1/2, YOU'RE ALSO GETTING
A HOODIE.
KEEP DROPPING YOUR TAKES OVER
THE COURSE OF THE SHOW IN THE
COMMENTS.
I'LL READ A FEW.
AFTER THE GAME ONE WINNER TO
GIVE AWAY A $250 SNEAKER GIFT
CARD UPGRADE THE SUMMER LOOK.
IF YOU WANT TO SEND IT TO ERIN
DOLAN YOU ARE WELCOME TO,
SHARING IS CARING.
WE HAVE TWO MORE KICKS TO GIVE
AWAY IN THE SHOW.
WHEN THE PAR LAY HITS, IT'S LIKE
THE HOME RUN DERBY, BANG.
WILL THERE WILL BE TWO
THREE-POINTERS MADE IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF ITS FIRST
QUARTER AND TWO THREE-POINTERS
MADE IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES
OF THE THIRD QUARTER?
SO THREE BY TWOS IN THE FIRST
HALF AND THE SECOND HALF, LAST
WEEK WE LOCKED IN THE THREE BY
TWO PAR LAY AND IT HIT.
GO TO THE VIDEO, PLEASE.
WE GOT JAE CROWDER, ON A
MISSION.
BRIDGES, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SIR, FROM THE CORNER.
THAT'S A THREE BY TWO IN THE
FIRST QUARTER.
SECOND HALF, DREW HOLIDAY HAD
FIVE THREE-POINTERS AND FROM
DISTANCE, D. BOOK THE
THREE-BY-TWO HITS.
THIS IS THE ODDS BOOTH FROM FAN
DU
DUEL, PLUS 400.
THE BUCKS HAVE HIT 39
THREE-POINTERS, WE KNOW THERE'S
FIRE POWER, ERIN, ARE YOU
LOCKING IN TO THREE-BY-TWO PAR
LAY?
>> OF COURSE.
YOU HAVE TO BET IT.
MAYBE WE SHOULD MAKE SHIRTS
"INSTEAD OF JUST DO IT, BET IT."
GAME TWO THAT WAS AT PLUS 440,
NOW PLUS 400 A GREAT VALUE FOR
THE GAME.
I WOULDN'T BET YOUR BANK ROLL.
SPRINKLE MONEY.
IT'S FUN.
PLAYERS KEEP AN EYE ON DEVIN
BOOKER FOR ONE.
THEY HAVE TO STEP UP AFTER THE
GAME THREE PERFORMANCE AND KHRIS
MIDDLETOWN PLAYS WELL AT HOME.
THE ONE THING ABOUT HIM AND DREW
HOLIDAY AFTER THAT THIRD QUARTER
PERFORMANCE LAST GAME, KEEP AN
EYE ON HIM FOR CASHING THIS.
>> WE NEED TO YOU GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET US KNOW IF THE
THREE-BY-TWO HITS AND I NEED
NAMES.
I WANT SPECIFIC NAMES OF THE
PLAYERS YOU BELIEVE WILL HIT THE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
QUARTER AND THE TWO
THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE THIRD
QUARTER.
ONE THING, TWO THINGS I LOVE
ABOUT YOU, ERIN, YOU BRING GREAT
DATA AND GIVEN US MERCH IDEAS.
BET ON A T-SHIRT.
WITH THE LOGO?
>> ALWAYS.
>> ARE WE EVER, YOU MIGHT NEED A
CUT THOUGH.
>> I DO WANT TO TAKE A CUT OF
THAT.
WE HAVE IT RECORDED THIS IS MY
IDEA.
I'M STEALING NIKE'S THING, BUT
YEAH.
>> JUST BETTING ON NIKE --
ANYWAY WE'LL DISCUSS.
APPRECIATE THE IDEA, THOUGH.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS
HERE.
I NEED NAMES.
LOOKING FOR NAMES IN THE
THREE-BY-TWO PAR LLAY.
REFRESH AND TO THE TOP.
OOH, THIS IS DOPE.
ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
GOT A BUNCH OF TOTALS FOR
GIANNIS POINTS WHICH I
APPRECIATE, I'LL READ A COUPLE,
BASKETBALL BARBER IS 29 FOR
GIANNIS, NOT ZACH LEVINE,
APPRECIATE YOU CHECKING IN
AGAIN, THE UNDER, BAD SPORTS
TAKES IS DROPPING 40 TONIGHT AND
NEEDS TO STEP UP TONIGHT.
40 NEEDS TO STEP UP.
BAD SPORTS TAKES YOU'RE LIVING
UP TO YOUR NAME THERE, THAT IS A
BAD SPORTS TAKE.
NEEDS TO STEP UP.
LET'S SEE HERE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY NAMES, LADIES
AND GENTS.
>> DROP NAMES IF YOU WANT FREE
STUFF.
>> I HAVE TO GIVE AWAY A COUPLE
OF HOODIES.
IT'S REFRESHING.
SALUTE NAMELESS, I LIKE THAT YOU
CAME WITH THE, OH, IT'S GONE
THERE.
WHAT IS THAT AGAIN?
CHEY
CHEYENNE LEBEOUF?
ALEXANDER HAD HIS BIRTH DAY TWO
DAYS AGO AND THEY HAVE A SIMILAR
SPELLING THE FIRST NAMES.
OKAY, NOT ZACH LEVINE THANKS.
DREW HOLIDAY WE'LL CATCH AND
SHOOT AND D. BOOK WILL HIT ONE
OFF THE SCREEN.
THANK YOU FOR THE DETAIL.
YOU'VE GOTTEN A HOODIE BEFORE,
YOU'RE GETTING ANOTHER ONE AND
ONE MORE HERE, KENYAN SPORTS 21
THE BEST BET AND RIDING AND PLUS
400.
LOCK FOR SURE.
IT WILL BE CROWDER AND DREW BOTH
CONTINUING TO BE HOPPING LAST
WEEK.
I NEED THEM KICKS.
KENYAN SPORTS 21 BECAUSE YOU
GAVE ME SO MUCH DETAIL IN THE
COMMENTS AND IT WAS A FIRE TAKE?
I NORMALLY GIVE AWAY HOODIES.
I'M GIVING AWAY A PAIR OF
SNEAKERS.
KENYAN SPORTS 21 THAT WAS A DOPE
COMMENT, YOU GET A PAIR OF
SNEAKERS.
I HAVE A COUPLE MORE HOODIES TO
GIVE AWAY.
>> THERE YOU GO, NOW PEOPLE WILL
START FIRING.
>> BOOKER HITTING ALL THREES,
WOW, THIS IS A BOUNCE BACK GAME
FOR D. BOOK.
SILLY ERIC, I APPRECIATE THAT.
I NEED GIFs.
ANYBODY GOT ANY GIFs?
LAST ONE.
WHO ELSE NEEDS A HOODIE?
GO WHITE SOX.
IF IT DID HIT THEN IT'S CHRIS
POWELL AND KHRIS MIDDLETOWN.
CHRIS AND KHRIS.
>> ONE WITH A C, ONE WITH A K.
>> YOU GET A HOODIE.
THE ROLE PLAYERS YOU MENTIONED
THIS EARLIER IN THE SHOW, ERIN,
ABOUT KHRIS MIDDLETOWN PLAYING
BETTER AT HOME.
GIVE ME BROOK LOPEZ FROM THE
QUARTER, P.J. TUCKER FROM THE
QUARTER, DEVIN BOOKER FOR SURE
WILL HAVE A BOUNCE BACK GAME.
MIKHAIL BRIDGES WITH THE
THREE-BY-TWO IN THE PREVIOUS
GAME WITH THE YELLOW KICKS.
IT WILL HIT IN GAME FOUR.
GLAD YOU ARE ON BOARD WITH ERIN
AND I IN THE GROUP CHAT.
WE ARE RIDING THROUGH.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> KICKER SPORTS 21 -- KENYAN
SPORTS 21 YOU HAVE YOUR FREE
KICKS.
LET'S GET RICH PLUS 400.
THE ONLY TRUE CONTENDERS FOR
FINALS MVP AT THIS POINT ARE THE
TWO FIRST BALLOT HALL OF FAMERS
PLAY IN THIS SERIES, THAT'S
CHRIS PAUL AND GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
WE ASKED YOU TODAY ON TWITTER,
WHO IS WINNING THE MVP, CP3 AT
THE TOP, GIANNIS, YOU SEE THE
ODDS.
THIS IS THE GRAPHIC.
LET'S SEE THE ODDS THERE OR THE
RESULTS FROM THIS TWITTER POLL
LAST WEEK CP3 FAVORED WITH 45%
OF THE VOTE.
TODAY PEOPLE ARE FEELING
GIANNIS.
MILWAUKEE 43% OF THE VOTE.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS.
THE UPDATED ODDS FOR FINALS MVP
WE TEASED YOU THERE ON THE OTHER
GRAPHIC, CHRIS PAUL NINE US 240,
HEAVY FAVORITE, ITS GREEK GOD
PLUS 220.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, WHO IS
WINNING FINALS MVP AND I NEED
REASONS.
I NEED THE PLAYER AND I NEED THE
REASON.
IF YOU WANT TO GO DOWN THE MENU,
IF YOU THINK DEVIN BOOKLER
CHANNEL THE BLACK MAMBA AND GO
OFF, GIVE US A REASON WHY.
DEANDRE WAS EFFECTIVE IN PHOENIX
AND TWO MORE GAMES IN PHOENIX HE
PUT UP BIG NUMBERS.
ERIN, HAVE YOU CHANGED YOUR MIND
FROM LAST WEEK WHO YOU'RE
LOCKING IN THE FINALS MVP?
>> LAST WEEK -- DMSH
>
>> AS THE FINALIST MVP.
>> WAIT FROM CP3.
THE ODDS MOVED OUT IN FAVOR OF
CP3 SO ODDSMAKERS AGREE CP3 IS
MOST LIKELY TO WIN FINALS MVP.
THE VALUE IS GIANNIS PLUS 220.
THERE IS ARGUMENT THERE IS VALUE
IN DEVIN BOOKER 12:1 BUT THE
ODDS ARE WAY TOO FAR OUT.
EITHER CHRIS PAUL OR GIANNIS.
I WANT TO STICK WITH MY PICK OF
CP3 WINNING BUT WAY TOO MUCH
JUICE.
IF I WERE TO BET INTO THE
MARKET, GIANNIS WOULD BE THE
PLAYER ESPECIALLY IF THE BUCKS
WIN THIS GAME BUT I THINK CP3
WILL WIN IT.
>> DID YOU WIN ANY MONEY ON THE
BUCKS GAME THREE WATCHING MIAMI?
DID YOU LOCK IN BUCKS MONEY LINE
OR I THINK THEY WERE MINUS
4 1/2?
>> I FELT THEY WERE GOING TO
COVER MINUS 4 1/2.
I WASN'T SURE, ROLLER COASTER,
BETTING ON THE BUCKS IS
NERVE-RACKING, SINCE THEY WERE
PLAYING AT HOME, WE WERE FEELING
THE VIBES.
>> SORRY, WERE YOU IN TAMPA BAY
WITH THE LIGHTNING OR SOUTH
BEACH?
>> WE WERE IN SOUTH BEACH.
>> YOU WERE IN SOUTH BEACH.
I LIKE THAT LIFESTYLE.
G MONEY SAYS IT'S A LIFESTYLE.
>> HE'S ALWAYS TOASTING IT'S A
LIFESTYLE.
>> YOU ARE LIVING THE LIFESTYLE.
WELL DONE.
I LIKE GIANNIS.
AND LAST WEEK, I BUY INTO THE
NARRATIVES, AND CHRIS PAUL IN
YEAR 16 IF HE WINS THE NBA
CHAMPIONSHIP HE'LL LIKELY BE THE
FINALS MVP.
AMAZING NARRATIVE BUT GIANNIS IS
A DUDE WHO CAME FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY TO OVERCOME SO MANY
BARRIER.
THAT NARRATIVE IS MORE
COMPELLING TO ME AND THE FACT
THAT'S PUTTING UP LIKE SHAQUILLE
O'NEAL NUMBERS IN THE FINALS,
AVERAGING 34, 14 POINTS, SORRY,
34 POINTS, 14 REBOUNDS AND 5
ASSISTS, THAT'S LIKE SHAQ IN THE
EARLY 2000s, THREE-PEAT BEFORE
YOU WERE BORN, PROBABLY HAVE
SEEN A GRAINY CLIP ON YOUTUBE
FROM TIME TO TIME BUT THAT'S HOW
THE GREEK GOD IS PLAYING.
I LIKE GIANNIS THE PLUS 220.
LET ME GET COMMENTS FROM THE
CHAT RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT, SO LET ME SEE HERE.
NAMELESS, OKAY, NAMELESS, YOU'RE
COMING STRONG.
I CAN'T GIVE YOU ANOTHER HOODIE
BUT YOU'RE COMING STRONG WITH
THE POINT GOD GIF THAT'S FIRE
THERE, MY G, WELL DONE.
LET'S SEE, NOT DEUCE TATUM SAYS
GIANNIS BECAUSE HE CAN'T BE
STOPPED, WITH AITEN OUT OF THE
GAME, I LIKE THAT TAKE.
WHO ELSE HAVE WE GOT HERE?
T. CAMPBELL 14 WRITES CP3 IS A
MORTAL LOCK, NOT JUST A REGULAR
LOCK.
THEY WON'T PICK JIGIANNIS IF TH
WIN THE SERIES.
HE IS THE ENGINE OF THE SUNS
TEAM.
MORTAL LOCK.
>> THAT'S A LOT TO LAY, MINUS
240, REALLY IS.
LOVE HEARING THAT WE HAVE A
MORTAL LOCK IN THE COMMENTS.
>> YES, AND THEN OH, GARRETT
BURG 13, THIS MIGHT BE -- SO THE
TWO OTHER ACCOUNTS THAT I READ
EXCEPT FOR NAMELESS, YOU GUYS
GET A HOODIE.
GARRETT YOU'RE GETTING A HOODIE.
GIANNIS IS FEELING LOOSE.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT'S HOW YOU
GET EXCITED OR PUT HEADPHONES
IN?
>> OOH.
I FEEL LIKE GIANNIS IS A
HEADPHONES GUY WALKING THROUGH
THE TUNNEL.
>> HE IS.
>> BUT THEN LIKE WHEN IT'S 10 OR
15 MINUTES BEFORE THE GAME,
THEN'S GOT TO GET LOOSE.
THERE'S SO MUCH NERVOUS ENERGY,
SO MUCH EXCITEMENT IN THE
BUILDING AND IN THE DISTRICT
WHERE THERE'S 25,000 PEOPLE.
>> JUST HEARING EVERYBODY
CHANTING ALREADY ALL DAY LONG.
>> YEAH.
"GIANNIS" OR "GREEK FREAK"?
DO YOU KNOW THE CHANT THERE IN
MILWAUKEE?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
THE LAST THING I THINK ABOUT IS
GOING TO MILWAUKEE FOR A GAME.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THERE IS TO DO
IN MILWAUKEE.
PEOPLE ARE TALKING IN TERMS OF
TRAVELING NOT GOING TO THE SUNS
BUT THEN MILWAUKEE AND THEY'RE
LIKE OH, MILWAUKEE.
>> THE NBA FINALS ARE CARRYING
ON.
GAME FOUR, THERE'S STILL GAME
SIX.
IF THERE IS A GAME SIX IT WILL
BE ELECTRIC.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WINNING
HOODIES AND I ACTUAL I HAD HAVE
TO GIVE AWAY A PAIR OF KICKS.
RICHIE 21, GIANNIS FINALS MVP,
UNSTOPPABLE DROPPING 40 PLUS
POINTS AND CARRYING THE BUCKS.
BUCKS IN SEVEN.
I LIKE THE GIF BECAUSE GIANNIS
HAS LIKE 1% BODY FAT SO EVERY
TIME HE JUST MOVES, YOU JUST SEE
LIKE THE MUSCLE FIBERS AND I
DON'T KNOW WHY I'M GETTING SO
SPECIFIC ON THIS BUT SALUTE TO
YOU.
>> HE'S RIPPED.
HE LOOKED LIKE A GREEK FREAK.
>> HE'S JACKED.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> I BLEMEAN THE TRICEPSUALS AN
THE BICEPSUALS.
>> I CAN'T COMPARE.
>> YOU WERE ON SOUTH BEACH, THE
CURLS AND THE TRIS.
>> I HAVE TO GET ON THE MACHINE
WHERE YOU PULL THE ROPE DOWN.
>> CALLED THE TRICEPS E TENSION
I THINK.
TONIGHT IS A PIVOTAL GAME FOUR
IN MILWAUKEE, TIP-OFF AT 9:00
P.M. EASTERN.
THE SUNS ARE LEADING THE SERIES
2-0.
HERE ARE THE ODDS FOR THE
CORRECT SERIES SCORE.
THIS IS ANOTHER PREDICTION, BUT
THERE'S SOME VALUE HERE, WILL
THE SERIES END 4-1, 4-2, 4-3,
GET IN THE COMMENTS TELL WHICH
TEAM IS WINNING THE SERIES AND
HOW MANY GAMES AND TELL ME WHY
TO GET YOUR HOODIES.
JUST LIKE IN HIGH SCHOOL MATH
CLASS YOU HAVE TO SHOW YOUR WORK
TO GET YOUR CREDIT.
ERIN, BEFORE WE GET TO YOUR
PREDICTION, HOW WERE YOU IN HIGH
SCHOOL MATH?
>> I DID HAVE STRAIGHT As BUT I
WASN'T IN THE FIRST TRACK OF IT.
I WAS GOOD AT SCIENCE, VERY GOOD
AT COMMUNICATION AND TALKING IN
CLASS BUT OTHER THAN THAT, MATH
WAS NOT MY STRONGEST SUBJECT.
>> RIGHT, BECAUSE SCIENCE AND
COMMUNICATION DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
ALGEBRA OR TRIGONOMETRY.
>> NO, IT'S ALL MEMORIZATION.
MAKES SENSE FOR MY JOB,
COMMUNICATION, MEMORIZING
THINGS, ESPECIALLY IN SCIENCE.
>> WELL DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
SO WHAT IS YOUR PREDICTION IN
THE SERIES FOR THE CORRECT
SCORE.
SUNS AND WHATEVER OR BUCKS AND
WHATEVER?
>> SUNS IN SIX.
THIS LAST WEEK PLUS 440, NOW
PLUS 320, GREAT VALUE.
THE SERIES CAN GO THE DISTANCE
IF THE BUCKS WIN TONIGHT.
BUCKS ARE STILL VERY MUCH A
ROLLER COASTER TO ME.
THE ENTIRE SEASON THEY WERE A
ROLLER COASTER.
AFTER GAME THREE PEOPLE THINK
WE'LL TAKE THE BUCKS IN SIX OR
SEVEN BUT I THINK THE SUNS ARE
PROBABLY HUMBLED BY GAME THREE
SO I'M STILL STICKING WITH THE
SUNS IN SIX.
I KNOW YOU DON'T AGREE WITH ME
ON THE SUNS WINNING OVERALL.
WE'RE NOT AGREEING ON ANYTHING
BASICALLY IN THE SHOW.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
BECAUSE YOU WENT TO SOUTH BEACH
AND DIDN'T GET NEW KICKS.
I'M ALREADY, WE'RE ALREADY
FIGHTING.
YOU MISSED A HUGE OPPORTUNITY.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET US
KNOW THE CORRECT, LET US KNOW
YOUR PREDICTIONS FOR THE CORRECT
SERIES SCORE AND I NEED TO KNOW
REASONS WHY LIKE ERIN JUST GAVE,
WONDERFUL SOLILOQUY WHY THE SUNS
WIN IN SIX AND GIVE AWAY
HOODIES.
I LIKE THE BUCKS IN SEVEN.
WE ARE ON OPPOSITE SIDES HERE.
WHEN IT COMES TO ELITE TEAMS M
Y
PLAYING AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL,
PART OF THE STRATEGY YOU TRY TO
FIND ADVANTAGES IN THE MARGIN.
THE NBA AS PLAYED IS SUCH A
PERIMETER GAME AND BOTH TEAMS
SHOOT THE THREE VERY WELL, SIZE
MATTERS AND MILWAUKEE IS A
TOUGH, PHYSICAL, BIGGER TEAM
THAN THE PHOENIX SUNS.
EVEN WHEN THEY PLAY SMALL BALL
THEY'RE BIGGER THAN THE SUNS,
TALKING ABOUT THE BUCKS AND
DEANDRE AIDAN HAS TO SIT DOWN
AND REST, THEY SEND OUT A SEVEN
FOOT BROOK LOPEZ AND 6'10" BOBBY
PORTIS TO GRAB REBOUNDS AND IF
KHRIS MIDDLETOWN PLAYS AT HIS
ALL-STAR CALIBER LEVEL THE BUCKS
CAN STEAL GAME FIVE IN PHOENIX
AND/OR GAME SEVEN IN PHOENIX, SO
GIVE ME BUCKS IN SEVEN.
I WANT TO SEE THIS BE AN
ABSOLUTE CLASSIC SERIES.
THAT'S WHAT I GOT.
LET ME QUICKLY GO TO THE
COMMENTS AND SEE WHAT WE GOT
HERE.
>> ARE YOU SEEING ANY SUNSET
VIBES?
STILL GETTING PEOPLE DOING THAT?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN MANY SUNSET
VIBES BUT I DO HAVE LET'S SEE
HERE, WE GOT NOT DEUCE TATUM IS
BACK.
BUCKS IN SIX, HOLIDAY FINDS HIS
GROOVE, I LIKE THAT.
>> OKAY.
>> GAME SIX IN ATLANTA 27-9-9 SO
HE HAS IT IN HIM FOR A BIG GAME.
DUDE SAYS BOOKER WILL BE A
SHOOTER AND YOU ARE GETTING A
HOODIE, WELL DONE, SIR.
LET ME SEE IF I CAN, DRO 305,
SUNS IN SEVEN, AND GIANNIS IS
PUTTING UP HUGE NUMBERS IN GAME
FOUR.
I LIKE THAT.
LET ME TRY TO FIND ANOTHER, OH,
OKAY.
CASH SAYS SUNS IN SIX, BOOKER
AND CP3 GOING TO CUT DOWN ON
TURNOVERS AND SCORE LIGHTS OUT.
THERE'S A DEVIN BOOKER GIF.
>> OKAY.
>> WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF DEVIN
BOOKER'S OUTFIT?
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO BRING
THAT OUT.
GABBY WAS MAKING ME LOOK AT
DEVIN BOOKER AS HE WALKED
THROUGH THE TUNNEL.
I WISH I COULD PUT IT ON SCREEN
BUT IT'S SHORTS, HIGH ANKLE
SOCKS, SOME DRESS SHOES, LONG
SLEEVE RED SHIRT AND THEN I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A LEVI'S
WHITE TEE OVER, BUTTON DOWN, ALL
AROUND HE LOOKS LIKE A DISASTER.
HE DIDN'T LIKE THIS PIC SO HE
DIDN'T POST IT.
>> HE ALSO DRESSED LIKE A
DISASTER, AND THEN HE PLAYED
TERRIBLY.
>> TEN POINTS AFTER THIS PIC?
CLEARLY THIS WAS THE ISSUE.
>> [ [ LAUGHS ] ] IF YOU HAVE
SOME LOVE IN THE COMMENTS FOR
DEVIN BOOKER, WE'D LOVE TO SEE
YOU.
LISTEN, I'M GOING TO SAY MAYBE
ONE MORE HOODIE.
TAPPY TEN HAS A GIF OF A BUNCH
OF SNEAKERS.
>> PEOPLE LOVE THE SNEAKERS,
SHOE GAME.
>> I HOPE YOU TAP IN.
>> WHAT DO YOU CALL PEOPLE
OBSESSED?
SHOEHEADS?
>> SNEAKERHEADS.
>> SNEAKERHEADS
>
>> THANK YOU FOR TAPPING INTO
THE APP PRESENTED BY FAN DUEL.
HOPEFULLY I GAVE AWAY ENOUGH
HOODIES AND HOPEFULLY I DID GREG
IVORY JUSTICE, HE'S THE MOST
GENEROUS MEMBER ON THE CREW.
WE ARE RIDING WITH THE OVER SLB
UNDER SCORING PROP 34 1/2 POPS.
CHRIS PAUL IS THE BETTING
FAVORITE TO WIN FINALIST MVP.
IF YOU BELIEVE MILWAUKEE CAN
TURN THIS AROUND THERE'S VALUE
IN GEE NANIS TO WINNING MVP AT
PLUS 220.
GET ON THE THREE-BY-TWO PARLAY
AND GET ON FAN DUE TOLL LOCK IN
THAT BET.
LET'S RIDE TOGETHER FIRST HALF,
SECOND HALF.
WE HAVE MORE KICKS TO GIVE AWAY
AFTER THE SHOW.
GET ON BRBETTING SOCIAL, THE BR
APP, AND BR KICKS ON SOCIAL AND
WHERE WE'LL BE GIVING AWAY THREE
ADDITIONAL PAIRS OF SNEAKERS
AFTER THE GAME.
IF THE SERIES GOES TO GAME SIX
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT TUESDAY, WHEN
WE'LL GIVE OUT ANOTHER SIX PAIRS
OF SNEAKERS $1,500, THANK YOU
FOR RIDING WITH US AND IF YOU
WANT A SNEAKER, A PAIR OF
SNEAKERS O
S OR A HOODIE TODL
DM YOU.
LAST THING IF YOU DO WIN A PAIR
OF SNEAKERS, FEEL FREE TO DONATE
THEM TO ERIN DOLAN, SHE NEEDS AN
UPGRADE IN HER CLOSET.
ALL SHE HAS ARE HEELS AND NOT
APPARENTLY A PAIR OF VANS.
THANK YOU FOR TAPPING INTO THE
GROUP CHAT ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN
I'M CABBY RICHARDS.
PEACE!